it's great to be joined today by Bobby
Azarian who is a cognitive
neuroscientist and blogger for
psychology today he's on Twitter at
Bobby Azarian in his new youtube channel
his road to Omega
Bobby great to have you on first and
foremost thank you thanks for having me
dude
so we've been exploring in a lot of
different ways politically culturally
reasons why Donald Trump continues to
enjoy a high 30s low 40s approval rating
and whether that seems to be what some
call a cult of personality around him
what others call cognitive dissonance
when it comes to his promises and the
reality and the unwavering support that
he still enjoys from for many in his
base you at the sort of cognitive
neuroscience level have identified a
number of phenomena that are responsible
for this unwavering support let's first
just to introduce people to sort of how
we're thinking about this how does this
field work and what are these phenomena
that you've identified so excuse me
there are a lot of people a lot of
reasons why people support Trump but I
think the ones that are the most
interesting and the ones that are most
important for people know about are the
ones that have some interesting
psychology and neuroscience behind them
and I think those explanations that are
explained not just support for Trump but
specifically this kind of unconditional
loyalty that we see this kind of
cult-like behavior and that's really
what makes Trump unique among you know
politicians and other presidents I mean
every president you know has their
supporters but Trump is able to get away
with things that would have sunk any
other politician like you know
everything there's obviously something
going on for Putin the Hollywood access
video where we talked about grabbing
women's vaginas those kind of things
would have you know destroyed the career
of any other politician Republican or
Democrat so when something like that
when we when we see that kind of
behavior
there's usually some interesting
psychology there and in this case
it really boils down to fear in a lot of
instances basically how Donald Trump
uses fear to keep that support strong
and this has to do with how the brain
responds to fear and our behavioral
response to fear so I can talk about
each of those things yes let's talk
about a term that people may not be
familiar with this terror management
theory and when people hear that they
might think that that's related to sort
of like law enforcement and preventing
terrorist attacks or something like that
but it actually comes from a book in the
70s called the denial of death and it
has to do with exactly what you're
talking about how human behavior is sort
of influenced by psychological phenomena
and how we respond to what politicians
say and do so let's let's focus in on
that first if we can how does that work
yes so terror management theory is kind
of complicated but when you understand
it it seems to explain like everything
that we're seeing right now as far as
like Donald Trump's unwavering support
and this growing nationalist movement
we're seeing not just in America but
globally and when I say tear it has to
do with existential terror we're talking
about fear of death or anything that
seems to be a threat to either you as an
individual or a threat to your way of
life so basically the theory is based on
as you said Blitzer Prize winning book
from the 70s called the denial of death
written by a cultural anthropologist
named Ernest Becker and Becker's big
idea was that humans have a unique
awareness of their own mortality so
unlike other animals we know that some
day we're going to die and probably be
forgotten and every trace of our
existence will be erased from history
which makes it kind of hard to go
through life so he believes that are
believed I should say that humans
created cultural worldviews worldviews
like religions political ideologies
national identities to ease
this constant fear of death that's kind
of always bubbling beneath the surface
and worldviews help mitigate this fear
of death by giving paths to immortality
and by that I mean religions provide a
path to literal immortality through the
concept of an afterlife while political
ideologies and national identities give
us what's called symbolic immortality
and that really refers to feeling like
we're part of a larger group and
identity and a movement that will
outlive the individual so worldviews
instill life with meaning and value and
distract from our fear of death and make
us feel like life's worth living there
basically death anxiety buffers so what
the theory predicts the hypothesis it
makes is that when people think about
existential fear or any sort of threat
or when they're subjected to scary
messages like fear-mongering what they
do to defend against that is that they
strengthen their cultural worldviews
since we're all views protect us from
this fear we tend to become more
ideologically extreme when we're fearful
and we tend to put more support into
those who share our worldviews and
become more aggressive toward those with
opposing world views
so basically existential fear makes us
behave more tribally and more hostile
toward those from outside cultures okay
so Melissa you make the case that this
is particularly noticeable with Trump
and to provide some context a lot of
what you're saying I wasn't missing from
President Obama so and it's different
but for example when you talk about
climate change and the existential
threat that climate changes maybe not to
us but to future generations by
participating in a fight against climate
change you are pushing back in
exactly the way you describe sort of
something bigger than ourselves
preserving the planet for future
generations that's just one example
right so what I would like to hear is
how is this more acute or pronounced
under the Trump sort of doctrine so to
speak yes so anytime you have
existential fear it's going to have this
effect the effect isn't always
predictable sometimes it pushes both
Republicans and Democrats towards the
right depending on the type of
existential threat other times it makes
people more extreme ideologically toward
whatever side they're already on so
things you know constantly talking about
the threat of climate change is going to
do that but that's a real threat so that
is something that we need to worry about
so you can't just not talk about a
threat because you're worried about the
effects that it might have if the
threats real on the other hand you know
with Donald Trump a lot of these threats
are exaggerated and that's really where
the problem is and the way he says it if
you if you watch some of the footage
where he's talking about there's a CNN
interview with Anderson Cooper saying
that Islam hates America and he just
says it over and over again and he said
that uh you know rally speech that Obama
was the founder of Isis he reiterated
that like five times for the audience so
when you have this existential fear
people are going to become more
supportive of you especially they become
more supportive of leaders with
nationalist messages and you know the
threat is real I mean Isis is real it's
something you know to be afraid of so
Donald Trump kind of used that to his
advantage and I think the the fears
around Isis kind of set the stage for
Donald Trump and cultural fears over
immigration in general kind of set the
stage for him but as far as like the
evidence for this term management theory
is supported by
hundreds of psychology neuroscience
studies that show that you know making
people think about existential fear
makes them more nationalistic and
creates like racial biases and so for
some specific examples we saw that after
9/11 George Bush went from being a
pretty unpopular president to a very
popular one another example of leader
with the nationalist messages becoming
our gaining support and a tear
management that study explored that and
showed that existential fear was related
to increased support for Bush a similar
study was done with Donald Trump and
this was conducted by the co-founder of
terror management theory so basically
they found that when people were made to
think of existential threat they became
more supportive of Donald Trump and
these same people viewed immigrants
moving into their neighborhood as an
existential threat Bobby to touch on one
of the other sort of pillars of what
we're talking about here in the sort of
limited time we have I'd like to talk
about the relationship of what we've
discussed so far the use of fear
existential threats etc and how that
interacts with the sort of entertainment
value of the way that Donald Trump has
run for president and has been president
so he holds people's attention between
the insults and the bombastic nature and
everything else in a way that Hillary
Clinton uniformly did not this is not a
commentary on their policies it's merely
an assessment of the way in which from
an entertainment perspective Donald
Trump was able to influence people can
you talk about how that relates to this
concept of unconditional support or
support that goes beyond the facts yes
so the way Donald Trump speaks and
gestures engages the brain more than
other politicians do when they're
speaking and that's something we know
from you know science studies we see
specifically the areas of the brain
involved in attention and emotion
are activated more strongly and for
longer times when Donald Trump is
speaking a company called narrow spark
did a study sparked neural actually they
did a study where they had participants
democrats and republicans watched like
an hour of footage of debates and
speeches right before the 2016
presidential election and they saw this
pattern where Donald Trump was
consistently engaging those brain areas
compared to Hillary Clinton who wasn't
really good at all at keeping the brain
engaged what was really interesting
about it is some people mentioned you
know not really being fans of Donald
Trump and they weren't intending to vote
for him but their brains were telling
this different story they were they were
showing like a lot of activation in
attention areas and when they followed
up with these people
months later some of them were Democrats
they found out you know some of them
confessed to actually voting for Trump
because ultimately they said you know
his messages resonated with them so
there seems to be something about the
way Trump talks I'm sure alive it has to
do with like simple language like you
said like no bombastic comments and just
his overall way of engaging people
probably learned that from being you
know a reality show host but he engages
everyone you know they're their brains
more strongly than other politicians the
reason that this is relates to the
unwavering support so this effect is is
amplified in conservatives because
conservatives have this hypersensitivity
to threat generally speaking so by that
I mean they tend to focus on threat more
and they tend to have this exaggerated
fear response to threatening messages so
we know this from a number of different
studies for example one study took
sir motives and liberals and had them
sit in front of a computer screen where
they showed a bunch of different images
some of the images were threatening
somewhere neutrals some are positive and
they track their eye movements and what
they found is that conservatives fixated
on the threatening images longer and
they oriented toward the threatening
images more quickly then liberals so
yeah we call that being hyper-vigilant
for threat and a couple other studies
showed that conservatives tend to have a
larger amygdala and a more reactive
amygdala in response to threat yes oh
the amygdala is a brain structure that
is involved in processing threat and
it's also associated with the fear
response
so when Donald Trump is saying these
scary messages their brains are engaged
even more strongly his messages are more
salient because they're in a way tuned
into threat and I'm not really trying to
pick on conservatives here that's what
the studies show also you know someone
could interpret that differently and you
could see it as Republicans or
conservatives might also be better
equipped to respond to a threat in the
case that you know something does happen
because they're they're hyper vigilant
absolutely fascinating stuff we've been
speaking with cognitive neuroscientist
Bobby Azarian who also blogs for
Psychology Today you can follow him on
twitter at bobby Azarian and check out
his new youtube channel road to omega
Bobby really a pleasure having you on
party to be here thanks David anytime